good afternoon everyone
welcome to this uh meeting of cabinet on
monday the 10th of january you will
notice that on your desks is the agenda
for monday the 17th of january however
we are running the meeting as of monday
the 10th
apologies for absence and
we
we have a
apologies from david buckland
thank you on
disclosures of interest any disclosures
of interest
no disclosures of interest good minutes
confirm and sign the minutes of the
meetings held on 6th and 9th of december
are there any issues on the minutes
councillor harvey
thank you leader uh minute 421 first
paragraph there is an apostrophe in the
wrong place
two councils
apostrophe comes after the s
more importantly uh the last paragraph
of that note before the recommendation
contains a nonsense it first refers to
the government's planning bill white
paper there is no such thing as a
planning bill white paper
it is
it should be referred to as the
government's quote planning for the
future white paper
thank you councillor harvey uh we will
amend the minutes to take on board your
comments
uh
so without further ado on to
uh
item for notice of motion tree planting
um
i would recommend
that of the options open to cabinet
we defer consideration to where to
report from officers
so i'm proposing that can i have a
second please
counselor jennings thank you
all those in favor
thank you members of cabinet
moving on to notice of motion
competitive bids and grants
uh i am proposing exactly the same thing
for this to defer consideration of the
of the motion to
await a report from officers to the next
available meeting of the cabinet can i
have a second to please councillor
shenton
thank you
so
moving slowly on
um
have you chairman agreed
second but i'm not sure that you've
actually taken the votes yes oh
all those in favour
thank you
councillor kettle um
might we be told when the report is made
how much officer time has been spent on
the two reports
please yes good good thinking councillor
kettle uh i would anticipate the the
reports are brief succinct and to the
point
i'm sure they will be but just how much
time officers have spent on them
yes
uh noted counselor kettle right item six
capital budget monitoring periods one
two eight
uh councillor harvey
thank you leader
the purpose of this paper is to keep
members informed of the progress made
over the first eight months of the year
in undertaking the council's intended
level of capital expenditure this year
table two on page 18 demonstrates the
intention now to undertake expenditure
of up to 21.7 million pounds this year
including section 106 projects
the position remains substantially
unchanged since it was last reported at
the end of period six
the current position is attributable in
very large measure to the decisions to
enter into the new waste disposal
contract with biffa and to fund
improvements of the equipment within the
district's leisure centers
if all this capital expenditure were to
be delivered as reported in table 1 on
page 17
the council's remaining accumulated
capital receipts and grants to the end
of november would have been reduced from
5.7 million pounds to 2.8 million pounds
paragraph 1.5 indicates that capital
expenditure of 6.5 million pounds was
has already been undertaken by the end
of november
in the first eight months of the year
therefore the sums spent or committed
uh amount to 31.1 of this year's
available budget of 21.7 million pounds
appendix 2 on pages 25 to 29 provides
summary information concerning the
various projects yet to be funded
through section 106 agreements 7.5
million shown on page 27 and those where
section 106 funds have been committed
1.2 million pounds as shown on page 29.
appendix 2 also shows at the foot of
page 29 that just under 1.1 million
pounds of community infrastructure levy
funds have now been committed to various
projects around the district in ulster
myanvale shipston and stratford the
previously agreed sil contribution to an
electrical vehicle charging point in
napton on the hill is no longer required
i ask therefore leader that the current
position on capital expenditure and
income for the period to the end of
november 2021 be received
ansel kettle did you have a question
did you want to interject anything or
not
all right so council junit
uh i just want to uh raise something
that was covered at the ovu and scrutiny
committee and it was a request from that
committee um that they wish some advice
should be given on
the amount of section 106 and whether
there can be any flexibility to help
with affordable housing
particularly since there will be an
affordable or it there was a proposal
for an affordable housing working group
um to look at
ways forward
by put forward by the chairman of that
committee um whether or not there could
be any flexibility of section 106 and
the chairman did uh note that and was
would have but obviously she's not here
today
unit councillor pemberton and then
councillor barker thank you um
i thought
all members understood that section 106
agreements were legal agreements entered
into
between the local planning authority and
the relevant developer
those agreements can only be varied by
a legal subsequently legal variation of
that agreement with
the developer
um
so i'm not entirely certain
what
what further
other than through
the usual training that members will
have had on planning matters overview
and scrutiny he's looking for i think
that it is
appropriate for this council to look at
opportunities to vary section 106
agreements i would expect the lead to be
taken on that by individual ward members
who would have knowledge of the
impact of section 106 agreements in
their own areas there is also
the the housing and
investment panel which can take a more
strategic and holistic approach to
decisions where we might as an authority
want to consider some variation i think
the answer is about are there specific
projects where there is some rationale
for seeking a variation of the money
rather than losing it
and i'm not entirely convinced
that other than ward members and the
housing investment panel there's a much
better way of finding out that i make
that as an observation it is entirely
right for overview and scrutiny to
um
call to account
the management of section 106 monies but
the basic question about whether they
can be varied um i i'm not quite sure i
understand why members
aren't already aware that that's the
position would be my observation but i'm
sure the chair of the housing investment
panel would be keen to take up
any opportunities for better more
strategic use of section 106 monies if
those opportunities were afforded thank
you council of pemberton councillor
barker do you have anything to add the
chairman of the housing investment panel
would be delighted to take more
advantage of a load more section 106
money if it was around and i have to say
that the housing investment panel
um
largely one of the things we do is
affordable housing i wasn't invited to
the last osc so i had no idea you were
going to discuss um
affordable housing and the need for yet
another working group on another subject
i hope that the chairman of osc will
come to me to discuss it
thank you councillor junaid
can i make it clear that i'm just
reporting from the ovun scrutiny
committee um that you know that is that
is that is the role that normally the
chair is here i'm the vice chair so it's
my duty to report
um that that it that is the case
understood counselor junior so
uh there have been no further
indications that people wish to speak
the recommendation on page 17
councillor harvey i assume you are
proposing this
and i have a second to please
councillor shenton all those in favor
you members of cabinet so moving on to
item seven
once again it's councillor harvey
thank you again leader
the purpose of this report is to inform
the cabinet of the revenue picture of
the council's finances to the end of
november 2021
i'd like to begin
i'd like to begin by asking members to
turn to appendix 3 on page 41.
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year is
17.4 million pounds
if we now turn to appendix 2 on page 39
we can see that the budget for the whole
year is for total expenditure of 27.4
million pounds and total income from
various sources of 11 billion pounds
the difference between these two numbers
therefore 15.5 million pounds in rounded
numbers
together with the net cost of benefits
of 182 000 pounds represents the total
amount to be funded from various sources
i.e that's 15.7 million pounds as set
out in appendix 2.
in addition appendix 2 also sets out
that as a result of the kovic pandemic
the council has received net contingency
uh civil contingency funding from the
government of 14.4 million pounds of
which 13.3 million pounds has already
been distributed in ways consistent with
the government's intentions leaving a
balance of 1.1 million pounds at the end
of last november
turning to the position at the end of
period 8 november we can see that on
page 39 that in round terms the
council's expenditure of 20.5 million
pounds was 1.8 million pounds more than
budgeted
this reflects a variety of management's
decisions across the council's
activities in light of the current
changed circumstances and the impact of
events these results also reflect a
number of decisions to initiate some
planned spending on the basis that it
would be financed by the release of
funds that have been previously
earmarked for those purposes
on the other hand income for the eight
months to november was budgeted to be
8.4 million pounds was similarly
exceeded by 2.1 million pounds and
totaled 10.5 million pounds
this reflects in part the success of the
garden waste collection scheme
net of the additional costs of recycling
as a result of the eddington fire
combined with the release of the
earmarked reserves to which i've already
referred
the overall position therefore is that
the net cost of the council's activities
to the end of november was 243
000 pounds less than had been budgeted
or put it another way
the net cost of the council's activities
to the end of november
was within 2.4 percent of the budgeted
figure
section 3 of the paper identifies the
principal items of variance from their
budgeted figures during the period april
to november whilst section 4 and
appendix 1
provide estimates for the out turn for
the full year of an unfavorable position
of 803
000 pounds
managers and heads of service are again
to be commended for providing these
estimates in the face of continuing
uncertainty surrounding the council's
finances
section six of the paper demonstrates
based on the estimated outcome for the
financial year as a whole
together with significant movements
between the council's reserves the
general reserve fund the key measure of
the council's financial health
will increase in round figures from 7.2
million pounds at the beginning of the
year to 8 million pounds at the end of
the year
importantly appendix 4 identifies the
council's current earmarked reserves as
they stood at the end of november 2021
reallocations of a number of these
earmarked reserves to the general
reserve fund will form part of the
proposals for the 2022-23 budget to be
considered by the cabinet at its next
meeting on the 17th of january
subject to any further information that
mr snow might be uh in a position to
provide about the prospects for the
remainder of the current financial year
and any questions members may have i ask
that the report be received
thank you councillor harvey uh any
issues that need raising members of
cabinet
councillor
barker can i take you to um i think i'm
in the right page appendix
five
which is the savings schedule
related to presumably the americas i
just want to flag up um some things
which have been put on here discussions
have started around options appears to
be
um what is mentioned in the final column
in november on the visitor information
center shop mobility shakespeare's
england venture house u-bus
um and the final item um which i do have
a question on um particularly
from my own perspective uh ubus
i would like
because we've had a better settlement
for that to put a marker
in the ground that i want um your burst
to continue thank you very much
um and all those other things which i
think are really really vital to our
operations in stratford um i again would
commend those how am i on the wrong page
you're looking confused and says tony
no
i'm not at all confused okay and the
other the specific response okay well
the final thing then is um
this may be that i have forgotten it but
an ongoing saving included in the budget
was to enforce on live developments only
that's what it says here
um
whereas actually
what seemed what happens quite a lot is
developments take place
and often it's when it's finished that
you discover
or it can be when it's finished
and so i i'm quite surprised that we
agreed to live developments only there
at any point
um that was the only those are the only
things i wanted to raise
thank you councillor harvey do you wish
to respond i do thank you
yeah on the question of shot mobility
you'll be reassured
um
councillor barker
that uh when we come to discuss the
budget next week you'll find that
there's as far as i recall there's no
change whatever in the shop mobility and
in fact
uh the budget has been prepared on the
basis that all service levels all
services currently provided
will continue that was a
a an underlying theme of the budget
preparations
um the playing enforcement i'll defer to
others all i can say to you is
that it depends what those what those
words mean i know from my own experience
in my own ward where development took
place
over two years ago there is an
enforcement issue about
an environmental offset issue and that
is as far as uh enforcement policy is
concerned that is considered a live
issue and it is being pursued
thank you
that was what i wanted to know
thank you chair i think i'd just like to
give some reassurance here my my view is
when they make reference to live
developments we're referring to
um ongoing cases that have not been
closed
so therefore
any any any percy any any enforcement
action will always be taken
whether you know it's it's not just
construction management plans
if it can be retro identifying a
retrospective
issue that might well have been
discovered
later on it enforcement is enforcement
in accordance with planning law
and as far as i'm connected to the live
developments
is is referring to cases that have not
been closed
where
you have a a situation where the
the time scale has elapsed from a
previous thing which can be obviously
the ten year rule
thank you councilor perry councillor
barker
perhaps a bit of commentary on that
because
that could mean something very different
i'm grateful that it appears to me what
it what what has been described but
that's not how i would ever read
can we make sure the minutes capture
that
counselor kettle
i mean presumably that is the discussion
we can have next week when we are
considering the budget properly
uh rather than today would that be
correct that would be absolutely correct
councillor kettle
so as there are no more
hands up
uh
the recommendation on page 31 has been
proposed by
councillor harvey can i have a second to
place
councillor barker
all those in favor
thank you members of cabinet
so moving on uh
nothing from cabinet committees on block
items
sorry
oh sorry issues arising from overview
and scrutiny committee
we've already had councillor junior
raising some issues council o'donnell
firstly um chair to apologize i was late
my clinic ran over it was just to
summarize nothing came back from the
reports that were submitted to the
committee we um we were very grateful to
have jack with us in our first session
he's going to be a very useful resource
um even though it technically was quite
a challenging meeting the first one for
him and it was just to say we talked
about a number of tasks and finished
groups along with external speakers to
bring in with our forward programme
so moving forward we'll be letting you
inform you more about the diary once we
have confirmation from the people
invited in
thank you councillor o'donnell on block
items our
cabinet work program and climate change
panels so we are just receiving the
minutes and noting the work
on other matters urgent business
do we have any urgent business mr perks
there is none
thank you mr perks in that case i
declare the meeting closed
not
available